so what did she say you can go outside
you don't need a mask if you're going to
be around people who are vaccinated or
not
that's what she said unless you're still
going to be in really crowded
stadiums and arenas she's still
suggesting even without a top on it if
you're outside you're close together you
might want to wear
a mask indoors dr wolinski said
something that seemed important
we know the virus spreads well indoors
and so if you're around people who are
not vaccinated she highly recommends
that
everybody wear a mask in that situation
that's what i got out of it
um and but let's get the nuance to
answers of those who have been saying
much the same thing
for quite some time tell me larry
again i'm glad that she's giving us
permission you know it's fine to issue
guidance that is totally fine and you
know i think that people want to hear
from the cdc they want to hear their
guidance
we need to get to a point in this
country as well where we can listen to
guidance and then people can have
the personal responsibility and personal
choice to make health decisions for
ourselves
if we feel good wearing a mask if it
makes us feel better it makes us feel
more safe then we should be allowed to
wear a mask and
wear a mask of your heart's content wear
one two three four five
be fully vaccinated wear a mask sleep in
a mask i don't care
but again what worries me about this is
pushing people to get
vaccinated and dangling that carrot in
front of their face you can live normal
life
if you get vaccinated i'm sorry but uh
that makes my ears perk up and it makes
me a little bit uncomfortable
i don't like hearing that and i don't
like dangling that carrot it's a
personal decision personal
responsibility let's get all the
information
and let people make those decisions for
themselves kaylee
sitting in the great state of florida i
felt as if i was watching an alternate
universe um from the biden era cdc
i mean she's telling us we're allowed to
go to church now uh president trump did
a whole press conference on that many
many months ago
we're allowed to go to restaurants well
hey here in florida we really never
stopped going to restaurants there was a
short period of time when we didn't
understand
covid where it made sense to shut
restaurants but as quickly as possible
we reopened them and did so safely and
then you can wear masks as you're
walking through a desolate field once
again this is basic common sense we know
that that's been acceptable it shouldn't
have to be
a big announcement and i would just say
that with regard to the cdc
under president biden they had a very
rough rough time out of the gate
with wolinski telling us you can go back
to school
even without all teachers being
vaccinated and then the teachers union
had an eruption and she said i walked
that back i was speaking in my personal
capacity whatever
that means and she said you can't get
covid once you've had the vaccine ever
and then she came back and had to walk
that back so really rough going
out of the gate from cdc director
wolinski well it's hard i would imagine
charlie if you know she's not a
politician
so exactly she's just trying to tell us
what she thinks is going on
based on the science that gets
complicated if somebody actually has an
agenda
right and that's the great thing about
politicians is that they have all the
answers they don't have just some of the
answers
or just the answers in their words right
exactly they have all these
no the real problem here and and i i
agree with everybody that you know that
it's great to have this uh guidance from
the cdc it's great to have the cdc
but the problem is she's promoting
vaccine hesitancy
by saying that you can get a vaccine be
fully vaccinated and you still can't be
around
be inside without a mask that promotes
vaccine hesitancy that is why so many
people in america that's interesting
like you know i love vaccines i love
medicine i love science i love all this
stuff
but if they're telling me that it
doesn't work well enough
that i can ditch the mask as soon as i'm
fully vaccinated
then i'm sort of suspicious about that
well
you know what there's no zero point
for risk in life right everything is
risk
and if you are getting vaccinated and
you're north of like
90 percent then tommy's right i mean
it's guidance that you can take
or not take based on your own life
experience
emily you right and remember the whole
purpose of the lockdown in the beginning
was to flatten the curve
it was to preserve the efficacy of the
medical system it wasn't too
and it wasn't to eradicate actual
infection so it's sort of an interesting
data point
uh that we keep circling around but
sometimes seem to ignore
i thought it was also interesting that
she was pointing to and kept pointing to
the efficacy of the vaccines to
underscore
and demonstrate the point that you then
needed to wear masks inside she's sort
of
lifting restrictions oh now you can go
out inside wearing masks
but most states have already been doing
that to kaylie's point and then to
charlie's point
well then what's different and to
tommy's points um i think it's an
interesting question that raises the
issue of enforcement
so if the guideline now if the rule is
that you can go outside without a mask
if you're fully vaccinated
then how do you check how do you know
does that mean that businesses then or
states and and local counties will they
make the issue that well since we can't
double check since we don't know
we'll make everyone wear a mask still do
we require a vaccine passport
all of those questions that get raised
when you talk about the actual
knowledge of it that leads to that
enforcement i wonder how
our government will navigate that wow
you know i read an article recently
that talked about the efficacy of the
flu shot and in some cases it's rocking
lower than 40 percent
we have vaccinations now that are more
than double that so i
i've never heard that kind of guideline
to wear a mask during flu season have
you you know
if if you and i harris had 90 percent
odds where would we be
you and i would both hitch a a flight to
vegas
and we'd stay there for a week and then
i would shop
you guys know i love the show